( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: WELCOME TO "THE
NIGHTLY SHOW."
I'M LARRY WILMORE.
TONIGHT, BIG SHOW TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
DEVASTATING EVENTS IN BALTIMORE.
LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
>> RIGHT NOW THE GOVERNOR OF
MARYLAND DECLARES A STATE OF
EMERGENCY, ACTIVATING THE
NATIONAL GUARD AFTER BALTIMORE
ERUPTS IN VIOLENCE OVERNIGHT.
A CITYWIDE CURFEW HAS BEEN
IMPOSED, SCHOOL CANCELED.
>> Larry: YAY!
SCHOOL CANCELED!
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
BECAUSE NOTHING SAYS PUBLIC
SAFETY LIKE 20,000 TEENAGERS
WITH NOTHING TO DO IN THE MIDDLE
OF A TUESDAY.
( APPLAUSE )
THAT'S NOT GONNA BE GOOD.
THE NEWS COVERAGE HAS BEEN NONE
STOP, AND SOME REPORTERS SEEM TO
BE A LITTLE OUT OF THEIR ELEMENT
IN THE CHARM CITY.
>> YOU JUST SAW A HAIR-- YOU
KNOW A-- A-- A WEAVE STORE, A
HAIR STORE.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: DON'T WORRY,
ANDERSON COOPER.
YOU CAN SAY "WEAVE STORE."
IT'S NOT THE "N" WORD FOR
CHRIST'S SAKE
CNN'S PLUCKY KID REPORTER DON
LEMON, ON THE OTHER HAND, HE
JUST NEEDS TO STOP TRYING.
EVEN THE GOVERNOR OF MARYLAND
AND THE MAYOR OF BALTIMORE
WALKED AWAY WHEN DON TRIED TO
SUGGEST THEY WEREN'T HANDLING
THE RIOTS WELL.
>> IS THERE ANYTHING YOU WOULD
DO DIFFERENTLY?
WHEN YOU SAY OUTSIDE AGITATORS,
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO ENFORCE A
CURFEW TOMORROW WHEN KIDS ARE
OUT OF SCHOOL?
SAY AGAIN, MAYOR, I'M SORRY.
( LAUGHTER )
>> Larry: HEY, HEY, YOU KNOW
WHAT THEY SAY.
WHEN LIFE HANDS YOU DON LEMON,
YOU WALK THE ( BLEEP ) OUT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT.
THAT'S HOW THE SAYING GOES.
CNN TOOK THE AWKWARD APPROACH TO
HANDLING RACIAL TENSIONS, AND
FOX TOOK THE RACIAL APPROACH TO
HANDLE THEIR AWKWARD TENSIONS.
>> WE HAVE TWO STORES.
THIS GUY IS WALKING OUT WITH A
COLT 45 POSTER AND BURNING IT.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF FREE LIQUOR
WITH THE THE FIVE-FINGER PROGRAM
HERE.
>> Larry: THAT WAS A CLIP FROM
FOX NEWS' "BLACKS DO THE
DARNDEST THINGS!."
BUT FOX LOVES A GOOD COMPARISON,
AND THOSE COMPARISONS DON'T GET
CONFUSED WITH ANNOYING THINGS
LIKE LOGIC.
>> THIS DOESN'T LOOK OR FEEL
LIKE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> THIS LOOKS LIKE SOME RIOT IN
SOME THIRD WORLD NATION.
"THIS DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS LOOKS LIKE A THIRD WORLD
NATION.
I CAN'T RELATE."
LET ME GIVE YOU GUYS SOME
ADVICE.
WHEN ( BLEEP ) LIKE THIS GOES
DOWN, ALL OF YOU SHOULD JUST GO
HOME SHOW RERUNS OF "KILLING
JESUS."
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO
RELATE TO THIS BUT IF ANYTHING
EXPLAINS AMERICA, IT'S THOSE
PICTURES.
OPPRESSION-RIOT-OPPRESSION-RIOT
IS EXACTLY THE PATTERN THAT
BUILT THIS COUNTRY. STARTING
WITH THE TAX OPPRESSION
WHICH LED TO THE TEA PARTY, THE
PARTY YOU ALL SEEM SO IN LOVE
WITH.
( APPLAUSE )
WHAT'S NEXT?
>> I'D BE INTERESTED IN
HEARING FROM THOSE POLICE
ABOUT THEIR LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATIONS HAVING TO STAND AND
WATCH THESE THUGS GO THUGGING.
>> Larry: "THUGS GO THUGGING
?" WHAT IS THAT, THE 13th
DAY OF CHRISTMAS?
13 THUGS-A-THUGGING, MAKES
SENSE.
F.Y.I., THERE ARE NO MORE GOLDEN
RINGS BECAUSE OF ALL THOSE
THUGS.
( LAUGHTER )
ALL THE THUGGING.
SORRY ABOUT THAT, CHRISTMAS.
OKAY, SO THEY MENTION STEALING,
MALT LIQUOR THUGS.
WHAT ELSE IS LEFT ON THE
STEREOTYPE LIST?
I KNOW. BLACK SUPER-STRENGTH
>> WE WATCHED THIS AFTERNOON
WITH THESE BOULDERS HITTING
THESE COPS.
>> Larry: BOULDERS?
BLACK PEOPLE ARE DOING THIS.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE DOING.
SO BLACK PEOPLE CAN THROW
BOULDERS, THANKS.
I DIDN'T KNOW I COULD DO THAT.
OKAY, STEALING, MALT LIQUOR,
THUGS, SUPER STRENGTH, WHAT
ELSE?
>> YOU HAVE AN ALLIANCE THAT IS
CONCERNED ALL OFFICERS AROUND
THE COUNTRY ABOUT THE CRIPS AND
THE BLOOD AND THE THE BLACK
GUERILLA FAMILY IS WHAT IT'S
CALLED, A GANG IN WEST
BALTIMORE.
>> Larry: SO BETWEEN THE
BLOOD, CRIPS, AND BLACK
GUERILLAS.
HMMM... WHICH ONE OF THESE GANG
NAMES DO YOU THINK FOX LIKES TO
SAY THE MOST?
>> THE BLACK GUERILLA FAMILY.
>> THE BLACK GUERILLA FAMILY A
GROUP KNOWN AS THE THE BLACK
GUERILLA FAMILY.
>> THIS GUERILLA GANG-- WHATEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT--
>> THE BLACK GUERILLA FAMILY.
>> Larry: ( BLEEP ) YOU,
( BLEEP ), MAN!
SERIOUSLY!
( BLEEP ).
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
WHAT KIND OF ( BLEEP )-- THAT'S
ROLLING OFF YOUR TONGUES A
LITTLE TOO GLEEFULLY.
YOU SOUND LIKE FIVE-YEAR-OLDS
WHO JUST LEARNED THE WORD
VAGINA-- VAGINA, VAGINA, VAGINA.
( LAUGHTER )
HOWEVER, HOWEVER, THERE WAS A
LEGITIMATE REASON TO TALK ABOUT
GANGS.
>> WORD TONIGHT OF A CREDIBLE
THREAT THAT SEVERAL GANGS IN
BALTIMORE HAVE FORGED AN
ALLIANCE TO ENGAGE IN ATTACKS ON
POLICE OFFICERS.
>> Larry: OH, THAT DOES NOT
SOUND GOOD.
IN FACT, THAT'S A PRETTY SERIOUS
ACCUSATION.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I SHOULDN'T
BELIEVE IT.
I MEAN, THEY ARE GANG MEMBERS.
BUT YOU KNOW IT, IT WOULD BE
NICE TO HEAR FROM ONE OF THEM.
I MEAN, I DON'T WANT TO PAINT
THE WRONG PICTURE OF THIS.
>> WE DO NOT COME TOGETHER
AGAINST THE COPS.
WE'RE NOT ABOUT TO ALLOW YOU TO
PAINT THIS PICTURE OF US.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE )
>> Larry: SORRY ABOUT THAT.
MY BAD, POLITE GANG MEMBER PRESS
SECRETARY.
PLEASE GO ON.
>> WE HAVE SOLDIERS OUT HERE
RIGHT NOW.
WE DIRTY.
THEY THREW BOMBS AT US FOR
TRYING TO STOP WHAT'S GOING ON
RIGHT NOW.
YOU'RE NOT ABOUT TO DO THAT TO
US.
>> SO YOUR GAME PLAN TONIGHT HAS
BEEN TO STOP THE VIOLENCE.
>> TO STOP WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> Larry: IT'S ASTONISHING.
IF THINGS IN BALTIMORE ARE SO
BAD THAT THESE GROUPS WHO HAVE
NOT DONE A LOT OF GOOD IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY NOW WANT TO DO
GOOD IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY,
THAT'S SAYING SOMETHING.
WHEN THE BLOOD, THE CRIPS, AND
THE "B" "G" "F"s-- THAT'S
RIGHT, FOX,THAT'S HOW YOU SAY
IT-- ARE TELLING YOU TO TAKE
IT DOWN A NOTCH, MAYBE IT'S
TIME TO LISTEN.
LOOK, THERE'S A LOT OFANGER AND
A LOT OF FRUSTRATION, AND, YES,
THERE ARE A THE LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE VANDALIZED THE CITY.
BUT THERE'S EVEN MORE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE TURNED UP TO DO SOME GOOD
SINCE SATURDAY THERE HAVE BEEN
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE PEACEFULLY
PROTESTING AND TODAY OVER ON
FACEBOOK OVER 3,000 PEOPLE HAVE
VOLUNTEERED HELP CLEAN UP THE
CITY.
BY FACEBOOK PARTY INVITE MATH,
THAT'S LIKE 300 PEOPLE, BUT--
( LAUGHTER )
BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE MORE THAN
BROOMS TO CLEAN UP THE MESSES IN
CITIES LIKE BALTIMORE.
STAY IN THE STRUGGLE.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ).